I have the Mr President of United States
to Kiev today the results of this visit
will surely be seen and will surely have
a reflection on the battlefield and in
liberating our territories the decision
of the United States on Abrams tanks for
Ukraine has already
presented a foundation for establishing
the tank Coalition and it's a historic
importance in many other aspects more
specifically near defense and Patriots
for the defense of our cities now this
is a very fundamental crucial
reinforcement of our capacities we've
also talked about long-range weapons and
the weapons that may still be supplied
to Ukraine even though it wasn't applied
before the I I know Mr President that
there will be a very significant package
of security support to Ukraine and
currently it will all serve as a clear
signal that Russia's attempts of Revenge
will have no chance and that we will
together defend our recipients and
citizens from Russia's tour will have a
more impetus towards our Victory and
today we have yet again underlying that
we have our common Vision with regards
to the perspectives of this war we have
coordinated the uh follow-on pressure on
the terrorist State we are working hard
on the reinforcement of sanctions both
bilaterally and in the form of G7 which
is very important we have common Vision
on the contents of many aspects of our
peace formula yeah because it's security
elements as well as the tasks to restore
the urine Charter to its full capacity
and to defend the international
rule-based order that's a common a joint
task for all the countries that are
interested in the International Security
the rebuilding and the uh the recovery
of justice is also very important for
all those who uh was affected by the
Russian Terror by the Russian war and
the aguasa has to take responsibility
for the aggression and to reimburse all
the damages and thank to the president
of the United States for supporting our
work on restoring the Justice more
specifically in the work of our all of
our institutions in that area and we
believe there's no alternatives to the
establishment of the special tribunal
this is the position of the United of
Ukraine and we shall support this
position and I would really like United
States to be engaged in the
implementation of our peace formula
because its implementation would mean a
reinforcement of global stability and
the predictability of international
relations and we have some achievements
in this area already this week in New
York together with the United States of
America
she's to this moment and over 16 other
countries will be submitting for the
consideration of the grand general
assembly of the draft resolution on
supporting peace in Ukraine and on the
end of the 24th of February we believe
that the approval of this resolution
would be a very significant evidence to
the fact that the terrorist state would
never break a civilized country and I
think
we are also opening a special tablet
dedicated to the President Biden the
first call and the night of the 24th of
February took place with the United
States and since that time we had
conversations and there were it was very
significant attention to uh horrified to
the protection of Ukraine's democracy
besides there's the personal
contribution and President Biden in
solidified the liberty and democracy in
the world this will remain will be
remembered internally and Ukraine is
grateful to you Mr President to all the
uh U.S citizens to all those who cherish
Freedom just as we cherish them glory to
our Warriors logo to our uh allies and
glory to Ukraine or the United States of
America thank you very much Mr President
you know it was uh it was one year ago
this week
and we spoke on the telephone Mr
President
it was very late at night in Washington
very early in the morning here in Kiev
Russian planes were in the air and tanks
were rolling across your border
you told me
that you could hear the explosions in
the background
I'll never forget that
and the world was about to change
I remembered vividly
because I asked you I asked you next
I asked you what is there Mr President
what can I do for you
how can I be of help
and I know they remember what you said
to me but you said and I quote
gather the leaders of the world
ask them to support Ukraine
gather the leaders of the world and ask
them
support Ukraine
and you said that you didn't know one
would be able to speak again
that dark night
one year ago
the world was literally at the time
bracing for the fall of Keith
seems like a lot longer ago than a year
but think back to that year
perhaps even the end of Ukraine
you know one year later Keith stands
and Ukraine stands
democracy stands
the Americans stand with you and the
world stands with you
Kiev has captured a part of my heart I
must say
I've come here six times as vice
president
once as president
and in 2009 as vice president when I
first came here
then back in 2014 I came three times in
the aftermath of the revolution of
dignity
and I again came in 2015.
to address the Rada
about the work of building a strong
democracy
and I came in 2017.
just before I left office as vice
president
I knew I'd be back but I wanted to be
sure
even though we the election were over
Brock and I were out of office
I decided to make one more trip
before the next president was sworn in
to Keith
so president zielinski you deeply honor
me
here in key with you today
to meet with your military your
intelligence folks your diplomatic teams
Community leaders who have stepped up
and helped their country
in their hour of need as astounding who
stood up everybody
everybody
women
young children
trying to do something with this trying
to do something
pulling people out of apartments and
being Sheldon literally I think is a war
crimes
it's astounding
in the whole world
the whole world
sees it
and looks at it
this is the largest land war in Europe
and three quarters of a century
and you're succeeding
against all and every expectation except
your own
we have every confidence that you're
going to continue to prevail
you know uh
from the moment I first received an
intellectually support in the fall
about a year ago
we were focused on determining
how do we rally the rest of the world
how do I help you with the promise you
asked me to make to Rally the world
well
how do you succeed
I'd ever get a world to respond
to a prosperous economy a confident
democracy
a secure and independent state
when United Americans of all political
backgrounds decided that they would
step up
American people know it matters
unchecked aggression
is a threat to all of us
we build a coalition of nations from the
Atlantic to the Pacific
NATO
to the in the Atlantic Japan and the
Pacific I mean across the across the
world
the number of nations that have over 50
help Ukraine defend itself unprecedented
military economic and humanitarian
support
we United the leading economies of the
world to impose unprecedented costs
that are squeezing Russia's economic
lifelines
together
we've committed nearly 700 tanks
and thousands of armored vehicles
one thousand artillery systems
more than two million rounds of
artillery ammunition
more than 50 Advanced launch rocket
systems anti-ship and air defense
systems
all defend you to defend Ukraine and
that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars were
going to be we're announcing with you
today and tomorrow
that's going to be coming your way
and that's just the United States in
this piece
and just today
that announcement includes artillery
ammunition for high Mars and howitzers
more javelins anti-armory systems air
surveillance Radars they'll protect
Ukrainian people from Aero bombardments
later this week we will announce
additional sanctions
against Elites and companies that are
trying to evade sanctions and backfill
Russia's War Machine
and thanks to bipartisan support in
Congress
this week we are delivering billions in
direct budgetary support
billions in direct budgetary support
which the government can put to use
immediately and help provide for basic
Services of citizens
the cost that Ukraine has had to bear
has been extraordinarily High
and the sacrifices
have been far too great they've been met
with them in far too great
we mourn alongside the families of those
who've been lost to the brutal and
unjust War
we know that they'll be very difficult
days and weeks and years ahead
but Russia's aim was to wipe Ukraine off
the map
Putin's war of Conquest is failing
Russia's military has lost half its
territory it once occupied
young talented Russians are fleeing out
of tens of thousands not wanting to come
back to Russia
not not just fleeing from the military
fleeing from Russia itself
because they see no future in their
country
Russia's economy is now a Backwater
isolated and struggling
Putin thought Ukraine was weak
and the West Was divided
as you know Mr President I said to you
in the beginning he's counting on us
not sticking together
he was counting on inability to keep
NATO United
is counting us not to be able to bring
in others
on the side of Ukraine
he thought he could Outlast us
I don't think he's thinking that right
now
God knows what he's thinking I don't
think he's thinking that
but he's just been plain wrong
plain wrong
and one year later
the evidence is right here in this room
we stand here together
Mr President
I'm delighted to be able to repay your
visit to our country
in Washington not long ago you told us
you told the Congress quote we have no
fear
nor should anyone in the world have it
end of quote
you and all ukrainians
Mr President
remind the world
every single day with the meaning of the
word courage is
all sectors of your economy all walks
into all life
is astounding
astounding
remind us that freedom is priceless
it's worth fighting for
as long as it takes
and that's how long we're going to be
with you Mr President for as long as it
takes
we'll do it
[Applause]
well there we are President Biden and
president zelenski making comments there
here in Kiev as uh President Biden makes
this surprise visit to this capital city
and it is extraordinary to think a year
ago almost a year ago when we were here
and Russian troops were threatening this
Capital City that are year on the
president of the United States would be
walking as you can see now through the
streets with President zielinski this
capital city is still secure and still
safe and zielinski president zielinski
saying this has to end with liberation
of all Ukrainian territory he said in
his remarks there
he welcomed the first president the
first visit from the president during
the War a most important visit he said
and he said our talks were positive and
fruitful and we're talking about a very
significant Security package including
long-range weapons he said and we will
keep the pressure up on what he called
the terrorist
State Joe Biden spoke of The Dark Knight
as he described it a year ago when
no one knew what would happen but he
said a year on Kiev stands Ukraine
stands democracy stands and he said it
was an honor to meet president zielinski
in the capital an honor to meet his
military leaders
and diplomats and he said you are
succeeding I am confident you will
prevail Putin's war of Conquest is
failing so let's go over to our security
and defense editor Deborah Haynes who's
also in Kiev and Deborah I guess it's
worth making the point you can't deny
the risks involved in
Joe Biden coming here like this
yeah you can only imagine the headaches
and the stress that must have been
security team trying to arrange for this
visit we know for ourselves we felt a
bit of that security code on didn't we
in the couple of hours before the
president came here to Saint Michael's
Monastery where he paid a visit with the
Ukrainian president they cordoned off
the whole of this area and not letting
us out of the hotel where we're staying
during the time that the president was
on the ground and across the capital
people commenting that the whole area
the whole Capital Central had been
locked down while the motorcade came in
it must have been incredibly
nerve-wracking because the only way into
this country at the moment is by Road
you can't just fly in quickly and fly
out and so they would have been very
mindful of the fact that this is a place
where Russian missiles do fall and as
you said there was an air raid siren
that went off which does happen quite
regularly while the president was on the
ground but what must president Putin be
thinking as he looks at the scenes in
the capital of Ukraine today it was his
ambition a year ago when he launched
this Invasion Invasion to topple the
Ukrainian government and to install a
pro-mosco regime instead the Ukrainian
president is still in power and not only
that the U.S president has chosen to
come and pay a visit that can't be going
down very well in the Kremlin
Deborah thank you very much indeed just
a quick word if we can before the top of
the hour with the Ukrainian MP Kira
rudick and I just wonder what you make
of these scenes in your Capital City
today
we are of course delighted and this
visit is a great symbol for all
ukrainians I want to remind everybody
that the work didn't start a year ago it
started on this day nine years ago and
this is why it is so important for us to
see that the world knows remembers
stands with Ukraine and that we are all
aligned on One mission for us to win the
war and leave in Victorious and peaceful
Ukraine
and what would your message be to
President Biden what do you think uh
president zielinski's message was to
President Biden
uh well my own message would be a year
from school full scale Invasion we are
running on one fuel this fuel is Hope
thank you so much for adding to our
ability to stand fight and hope for the
best for our country for that we need
air defense systems we need more weapons
and we of course need fighter jets to
protect our skies I think it was very
personal for President Biden to be under
Airaid Sirens today because they were a
threat of the attack
um just an hour when he was in Ukraine
and so so we can tell about people that
they should not be afraid that we can
protect them we do need the fighter jet
the reality is though that the war goes
on and Russia is talking about this new
offensive they are not going to give up
how do you see the next few months
we are fighting for our motherland we
are not giving up 100 and this is why we
are going to use all the matters that
are in our hands all the help all the
support to uh to win and to kick them
away from our territory from uh our
cities and make sure that uh we figure
out how to do so they cannot attack us
again so the next month will be tough we
know that but what is our alternative
there is no alternative
and looking ahead you know it's clear
that this could be a long war is Ukraine
prepared for you know a long war and
more pertinently do you think that the
West is prepared to continue this help
for for the Long Haul
well the desire of a long War it's a
Putin's plan he wants to direct
everybody into a long War uh hoping that
the unity will not stand president
zielinski said that we are fighting for
a quick War so we need to be able to uh
finish it as soon as possible and this
is why we are calling for everybody to
mobilize their support to make the
decisions that were probably postponed
but to make them now so that we can get
uh all the means that we need to fight
back we are ready to fight our men and
women are ready to fight and we know
that we are fighting for every single
day so for that we need the weapons so
if we receive enough of the weapons we
do not see why it should be a long War
okay Kira rudick appreciate your time uh
we're coming to the top of the hour
thank you very much indeed so there we
are these are extraordinary images from
Kiev President Joe Biden on an historic
visit to this capital city
this is Sky News today it's 11 o'clock
in the UK 1pm here in Kiev the headlines
President Biden makes an unexpected
visit to the Ukrainian Capital Kiev
he's met president zielinski who said
the visit is an extremely important sign
of support for all ukrainians
he stands
and Ukraine stands
democracy stands
the Americans stand with you and the
world stands with you